[Music]
welcome to the pledges very own version
of University Challenge and here's your
starter for 10 when is it fair to
discriminate against a student who
slaved away diligently for two years to
land the highest grades possible at a
level 3 a star's but deny them the
chance to study at one of the world's
finest universities come on come on
well pitiful the answer is when those
students apply to go to Oxford
University in a break with 900 years of
tradition Oxford is to hand out 250
places to students who do not need to
get the best grades indeed instead of
three a stars or a's and a b b will get
you to the dreaming spires it's an
attempt to help disadvantaged students
gain the sort of education they would
not usually dream of but justifiably
private school pupils middle class
parents teachers and heads are pretty
peeved it's not the fault of the student
they have rich parents and we're
fortunate to attend a posh school so
this house believes this is an unfair
and just unjustifiable assault on
assumed privilege discuss I love this
term assumed pretty privileged like even
the idea that something is privileged is
contested I mean this nothing is more
textbook to me than this of that phrase
when you're accustomed to privileged
equality feels like oppression yeah we
have 7% of British kids go to state
school forty-one percent of them end up
at Oxford and we know that obviously go
to private school yes we know the Oxford
is funneling people into the best and
the most influential jobs like
journalism and like politics if we're
going to tackle this level of social
inequality we have to actively do
something to change the kind of
structural and systemic reasons why
people
disadvantages you might not be able to
see them they definitely do you're
missing my central point why is it fair
to discriminate against a kid whose work
two years to gets three days start
respond yes would like to say to me the
issue of not having enough spaces for
everyone who applies is not unique to
Oxford every year there will be
disappointed candidates applied to
selective universities across the globe
undergraduate study at Oxford is and has
always been very competitive the
introduction of these two programs will
make it even more competitive for those
students who are from more advantaged
backgrounds and are on the threshold of
getting an offer from Oxford but if
anything that should be motivation to
submit an even stronger application not
to be discouraged explain to me why yeah
a young man or woman has worked two
years yeah gets his or her a start
fortunately they went to a grammar
school or and I will say I put my kids
through private school I was alongside
families who didn't take summer holidays
who kept their car together with
cellotape or sticky tape so they could
put their kids through it is not the
preserve necessarily of the rich why
should that child be discriminated
because the same thing has been
happening to state schools kids for
centuries so at the moment if you look
at the statistics only 13% of state
school children who have the grades to
get into Russell Group universities
actually get into the everything
imminent so my point is what you've been
saying has been going on to state school
kids disproportionately to what we're
talking about now wrongs make a right
let me finish
in terms of Oxford and I'll disclaim
I've been working with them on this
program around social mobility and
helping to get kids from disadvantaged
backgrounds into the University now we
know that what's happened is because of
those statistics in how few states
school children are getting into Russell
Group universities that are actually
Oxford and Cambridge were some of the
worst offenders on that the questioner I
am
actively realizing that there is so much
untapped potential in the rest of
society they are now going to make sure
that they get those kids I'm not saying
we shouldn't be helping those kids but
how is it for just because the kids went
to private school why is he just but
you've said you've got the solution you
can tell me why it's for no justice by
birth I heard her answering your
question I think she sayings the
discrimination is already going on the
other one so let's have more
discrimination so so actually actually
the answer I heard June say at least is
whatever you try and level the playing
field because discrimination is already
happening
then that does result in to combine
Rachel's point with June's the people
that had the advantage feeling oppressed
but actually all you're doing is
leveling the playing field now those are
the answers I yes I will give my view
now um look the the the figure that was
the statistic that was quoted on it's 42
percent actually 42 percent of Oxbridge
places went to Primus group school
pupils though only seven percent of all
UK pupils attended private thing right
so yeah I think that I'm not gonna cry
over the fact that prior to this on this
program I've said I don't support quota
systems but I'm not going to cry over
this particular in fact that I think
I've lost this debate because I also
recognize and this is where I'm really
really surprised you've taken this line
long that there's a huge injustice going
on and the huge injustice that's been
going on and that is that people that
can afford to pay for education and
those who can't and that privilege stays
within which is lost thinks I finish my
point is that the last thing I'll say is
that some of the most hard access in
June you'll know this we've spoken about
this before some of the most hard to
access disadvantaged kids in this
country are white working-class kids who
also need help and it's this is not
pitting races against each other it's
about opportunity and disadvantage and
those white working-class kids the house
restaurant oh okay so the best way to
give poor kids the chance to compete on
a level playing field a level playing
field
we had it years ago the best way was to
get them to grammar school it was the
greatest known engine of social mobility
you guys but you guys on the left just
one secret never talked about the how
you gonna pay for any kind of education
free education whatever operational acts
nobody let me finish my sorry let me
finish my father's that was that was the
way to get kids so Shimabara want to
make you a quote from conservative
candidates fell on to measure and baby
he says if you're a black person you
don't want to be part of someone's quota
you want to be their own mode if you're
gonna say more black people should go to
Oxford and Cambridge I'm all for that
but you need to create a culture of
excellence in those communities and that
means do you even with such situations
long before University and most young
people I think would be horrified at the
thought have been given a quote special
place at University and when they get
there let's let me just finish that I'll
shut up lots of lots of people who go to
Oxford and Cambridge they're always come
top at everything so for some of these
disadvantage and I don't use that in
quote kids that might be inspirational
for them for the rest I think it would
be terrifying and and disheartening and
it will not make Oxford a positive
experience
well starters if we just go back to the
original stat that I quoted which is
that only 13% of the kids with the
grades are even getting into those
schools so there are lots of kids who
will have the grace who have the to a
stars and the a we're talking about
quotas let me finish
who now at least are gonna have a chance
to get into that school and in terms of
the foundation program so again like I
said I worked with Lady Margaret Hall
when they started this and absolute
credit to Alan Ross puja for bringing
this system in and here is an actual
quote from one of the young people who
was on this program the the foundation
program into Oxford and this is what
sure Elma lungo had to say she said as a
young woman from neuen
Oxford seemed a distant dream but since
arriving in September 2017 I can't
imagine being anywhere else the
foundation year has changed my life and
today's announcement means many more
lives will be transformed and what
they're doing with the program is
expanding it out so they then cuts
across all colleges in 2020
don't want to help these disadvantaged
children I just I just don't think it's
fair to discriminate against them it's
removing their privilege that is not
discrimination they're already far ahead
if you want to level know they are
because of all the privilege that
they've had look by the time they get to
school they already are leagues and
bounds ahead because of all the
structural things that are going on that
mean that a kid from a richer background
is more likely to be better academically
than one from a poor background that's
just the way it is so if you want to
equalize that if you want to stop it
being that's social mobility in the UK
is so stuck that an OECD report last
year so it takes five generations i
poorer families to reach your point can
I ask a question I just like whenever
you level the playing field at any given
moment when there's inequality some
people will have to step back a bit yeah
there will be people watching the show
who are don't go on holidays who are
saving every possible dollar they can to
put their kids their sons and daughters
through perhaps I don't see why after
two years of studying they should be
discriminated we're going in circles
well that's a very small group the
majority of people in private schools
their parents have the means to put just
saying anyway coming up after the break
find out what caused this reaction at a
graduation ceremony in this day
[Laughter]
[Music]